[Music]
since you own your home i think this
would be a really like funny thing if
this happened to you um over in wales
there's a
these two neighbors that are feuding
uh because they they've been fighting
over six inches of real estate between
their homes wow that's crazy sales is
really small man people say six inches
is a lot bruh one guy oh no i'm sorry
it's it's
a lot it's essex but yeah their house
like there's a small i mean there's a
fence dividing it
and one one of the neighbors believes
that it should truly be six inches over
i would just say take it don't forget
yourself you really want this just go
[ __ ] yourself man but but is it like
do they live in a 400 square foot home
and it's like a small area no it doesn't
yeah how big are their homes i mean it
looks like this like this is that red
line you see right there is i don't know
the scale but that red line is the where
they believe the correct fence oh my god
practically like tracing the black line
it's very very small but basically what
happened is they did not let it go
and they continue to litigate over it
it's it's already hit three levels of
court and the judge is always saying
yeah you're right yeah you're right it
you should have that six inch you should
have that six hits they're all ruling in
favor of the guys saying like yeah it
should be mine but the the couple that's
uh defending it won't stop defending it
even though they're losing the case over
and over and over that now they have to
remortgage their house to pay for the
defense
that's how petty they are yeah oh my
gosh
neighbor discrepancy is is so funny like
my dad uh his old neighbor right behind
him he had like this big fruit tree i
forgot what fruit it was but then the
branches would grow over into my dad's
yard and then so my dad's like hey you
have to cut it man it's coming over
whatever and he goes no don't make it go
yo you had a body you cut it and then my
dad's like no this is not my problem i
don't have tree i don't want to cut it
and then he goes no if it go over and my
like they're like the the the walls only
like four feet tall and so my dad and
the other guy are [ __ ] just yelling
back and forth and [ __ ] and then i was
like
um like what's the what's the real
problem he's like well the fruits fall
and then you have flies and stuff so it
actually causes a mess yeah and i'm like
well do you also like
eat the fruits he goes yeah so i'm like
well you're also taking some of the you
know the good stuff and then what's
funny is they ended up agreeing that
they're gonna do it together
i was like so like so this is good
that's the best way
to set up a ladder and he has like a
chainsaw and my dad's on this side just
cutting so i look out the backyard and
there's just this [ __ ] this
vietnamese transplant
and then the guy's like [ __ ] up the
cigarette sticking out his mouth and
then my dad's cutting it too like that's
tight
it worked out the tree looked [ __ ] up
though because now that they both don't
know how to do it ruin the trip
right here right the trees like this
it's like really close to uh the wall
right this side is [ __ ] lush as [ __ ]
all of this you know when like old thick
branches get cut it's just flat
so it looked like a you know like a
chick with a side shape yeah yeah it was
just
it was too based
on one side
it's like it's like when william's
haircut had that wedge yeah yeah yeah
it was like that and i'm like damn you
gotta be arguing over some dumb [ __ ]
it's working neighbor drama man i'm so
glad i love my neighbors six inches of
space yeah just little things like that
people like you're gonna you're gonna
get bankruptcy over that so they're
gonna
how would you guys have handled it
because i would have been like they're
taking the loan out on their house to
pay
i wanna yeah it's six inches right so i
would have been like i'm like hey if you
if you want to redo the line
go ahead but you pay for the fence yeah
well the yeah the weird thing is they
said that they've been through a senior
county court judge who awarded the case
to the people that said that it was
rightly theirs like the um
the one saying move the fence
and then they took it to they appealed
it so it went to a high court and they
said yeah that's it's fine it stands and
then a court above that and they said
yeah it stands but they're still trying
to fight it
what the [ __ ] so there's no limit how
many more times they're going to go to
court as much money as you have you can
just keep on i guess keep on doing it it
could fit like a nice little flower
garden and that's probably why they're
like yo dude they're just we can't give
up that flower garden it's it's just
they want the flower garden that's uh
that's a real small flower garden six
inches exactly because what is this
that's a lot of flowers i want that line
um i want the fence moved right and i'm
like well if you want a fence move i
agree but you got to pay for all of it
but then what if they come back and be
like nah we got to share this because
we're neighbors and it wasn't supposed
to be there but i'm like but the fence
was there before i bought the house
i don't know man yeah those are the
people yeah that's the people there's
the people that refuse
these are the people that are going
broke
i might just take it dude and then
that's the fence that in question oh bro
that's so great
like they're that petty that they're
willing to [ __ ] burn their own house
down to prove a point i'll just go you
take these six inches and then on the
wall on this side
i paid that okay you can see it from
this image but that's basically the
fence right here and then this is
property one probably two is over here
that's so great it's six inches in a
yard like that see i'm not like really
into massive homes but then this is what
i envy about people that have a lot of
land
is you don't have to [ __ ] with nobody
yeah and no you don't have to deal with
any of that [ __ ] if you want to be an
[ __ ] you want to [ __ ] race
go-karts in your backyard if you want to
if you want to get your friends over to
play like a live music larp to learn yes
whatever
that's what i do yeah i have a friend
that owns a house in montana that he got
for like 300 grand you'd be larping over
there my heart's going to break here no
but then he has like 20 acres right
because he's like oh i was excited i was
exploring
i was exploring in my backyard what a
waste of space what a waste of land i
found a stream
i'm like
i found a stream there's fresh water
there's a stream and then he sent me a
story of like [ __ ] these deer that
come up to the stream and they're like
and i'm like do those deer belong to you
too like i guess so they're part of the
land dude you should build a water wheel
there the [ __ ] that's so dope yeah it's
just it just looks like a little
dude
looks like a postcard let's say like you
buy like a normal house like out here in
southern california right like a regular
10 million dollars three bed two bath
1.2 million dollar house above asking
[ __ ] torrance california right or
whatever
with that same price you can be a lord
in montana
a
yeah you have a whole manner you have a
whole [ __ ] estate you can name a
stream after you can buy mount rushmore
dude that's true
[Laughter]
you could find a mountain rushmore in
your own yard
you have a you have hunting ground yeah
just four asian dude faces on there yeah
[ __ ] you have a palace of versailles
dude that's how
much ballin you are when you go into a
different state so would you guys move
to montana hell yeah the midwest is that
is that midwest or west coast the north
midwest maybe
i don't know there's nothing out there
but nature so that's probably why
dude you guys got to look at real estate
56k dial up though there's
that's taking my tick tocks over there
one g on your guys got to check out
millionaire like ranch tour videos
montana and wyoming it's the [ __ ]
sickest [ __ ] they get these
videographers right and then they get
these drone shots of like all this they
have this like narrator that sounds like
a cowboy and they're like i like it
already yeah they'll be like white horse
ranch
located stream
that's the tagline or some squatters
there's a bunch of squatters there but
they don't even know yeah
yeah
there's a whole commune of squatters
[ __ ] whole village but they're like
super cool so you're like hey yeah you
can stay you could squat on my way roll
400 acres the only squatters you'll have
and it's pretty sick dude i know it is
it is really cool to see that what you
can get in places where there's no like
no business being there but it also
makes me very upset and very sad
sometimes i mean just all it makes me do
is just dream of an entirely remote
career that it doesn't matter where i am
the freedom part is sick but then when i
talk to my friends that do live there
they're like the thing that sucks is the
food stuff taco yes
there's like if you want anything
remotely even good you gotta drive like
three hours
you rationalize yourself you're like i
could live on a farm i could have a farm
at my place you know yeah well you can't
get banu out there oh you can't get
indian food but what you can do
is you can be
basically
like a medieval lord and you
you you hire chefs
yeah you'll be like you know what i want
indian food and then you just squire
hey i want an indian restaurant to come
over and then you have an indian
restaurant that comes over and then they
[ __ ] hook you up and then you're like
you know what tomorrow we're on mexican
food so you'd be like hey king taco can
you bring over your staff and they fly
over and then they cook you that is some
richy rich stuff yeah yeah
is that how it works
i think that's how it works because i
was thinking about it when i was grocery
shopping the other day and i'm like i
don't think melania trump
ever walks in to a grocery store
and gets like
cinnabon or some [ __ ] you know like
something i mean there's people in the
hollywood hills that don't walk into
grocery stores either that's right let's
just get everything delivered that's
crazy
so we got uber deliveries or we got
delivery but they got their chef going
in there their staff they get all that
stuff they cook it they get it ready and
then they just have to sit down and eat
they don't got to wash dishes they don't
have to do a dance one of my one of my
friends the the guy that trains
timbaland right now he gets his macros
and he just doesn't even give it a tim
bland he gives it to his chef
so chef makes all the food that needs to
eat for the day
all according to his macros and all the
timber has to just put in his mouth
he hasn't made music in ages yeah
that's so true
all those checks still paying him [ __ ]
dude he doesn't have to live in montana
either
where does he live where typically
florida probably like miami or like some
one of the bigger cities there
[Music]
[Music]